breaking benjamin frontmen Benjamin
Burnley has claimed that he was asked to
post about star wars battlefront on his
social network channels to promote the
game something he refused to do Burnley
shared an image of a broken battlefront
Xbox one disk through his Instagram
account this weekend along with a fiery
caption apparently he'd rather watched
the prequel films than play the game on
Halloween Burnley dressed up as kylo Ren
one of the villains and star wars the
force awakens perhaps VA's marketing
team or whatever group is handling the
game's promotional efforts saw this
Indian burn me to be a fitting candidate
to promote the game Burnley would not
have been the first high-profile person
to promote battlefront before this Sony
and EA enlisted pitch perfect and
Twilight star anna kendrick for a
live-action battlefront commercial she's
been posting about the game on twitter
where she has close to five million
followers battlefront launched on
november seventeenth and received
generally positive critical reception
looking ahead battlefront is getting
free the force awakens inspired DLC in
December with additional paid expansion
packs to follow in 2016 here's to hoping
that Burnley will give us an in-depth
review as to why he hated it so much but
in the meantime check out our review to
find out why we gave it a seven for more
on Star Wars Battlefront stay tuned to
gamespot